people they'll make an assumption
they'll have a little beast piece of
information and then make a roundabout
assumption and quite frankly quite
frankly these people are crazy
and they're just looking for clout
looking for money and it's unfortunate
because a lot of the
people the girl that made that video
about me I could list so many nice
things that my family's done for her
over the years like we gave her housing
in the Summers for free we I I remember
one time I took a test for her in
college I just did it like you know I'm
sorry I admitted to cheating okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I've learned her money
on like multiple occasions but the
second that it's profitable for her to
make a career off of me
um or you know money whatever clout
whatever she does it and it's
unfortunate but you know